شكرا طاهر مشاهدينا اهلا بكم في هذه
الساعه الاخباريه من العربيه والتي نخصص
معظمها لتغطيه التطورات السودان والبدايه
بالعناو
خلينا نقول بروايه او
بادراكين لخطور
السوداني يؤكده للعربيه موافقه طرفي
النزاع على محادثات لتثبيت الهدنه
اشتباكات عنيفه في احياء متفرقه في
الخرطوم وسط تحليق للطيران الحربي
الامم المتحده تؤكد فراغ 73 الف شخص من
السودان وصليب الاحمر يؤكد ان كارثه
انسانيه اكبر في الطريق
وفي اخبارنا ايضا
[موسيقى]
النقابات الفرنسيه اكد خروجا مليونين و300
الف متظاهر ضد ماكرون والحكومه تقول كان
العدد اقل من 300 الف
[موسيقى]
الهدوء النسبيه الذي عاشته مدن الخرطوم في
الهدنه السابقه اصبح الان امرا بعيدا
المنال بعد ان تواصلت الاشتباكات العنيفه
في مناطق مختلفه من العاصمه اليوم تم رصد
الطيران الحربي وهو يقصف مواقع في الخرطوم
فيما افادت مصادر بتحركات القوات الدعم
السريع رغم تمديد الهدنه يقول المبعوث
الاماميه للسودان فولكر بيغس في لقاء خاص
مع العربيه ان طرفي النزاع لم يلتزم ابدا
بالهدنه بشكل كامل لكن على سبيل الامل
يقول انه تم التوافق على اجراء محادثات
فنيه بين الجيش والدعم السريع من اجل
تثبيت الهدنه وحتى موعد اجراء هذه
المحادثات ربما ستظل هذه المشاهد هي
السائده في الخرطوم
[تصفيق]
هدف مع صوت صاروخ على ما
[موسيقى]
الاصوات للمدفعيه ثقيله فهي ثقيله لحد
البعيد واشتباكاته واضحه هنا
[موسيقى]
وقوات الشعب المسلحه
نسمع الان بوضوح من منطقه
وفي تفاصيل قال المبعوثه الامامي الى
السودان فولكرم في حديث خاص للعربيه ان
العمل جاري لوضع التفاصيل اللوجستيه
لمفاوضات السودان مع الامريكيين
والسعوديين
ورجح ان تجري مفاوضات الحل في السعوديه
مشيرا الى ان الاولويه الان لوقف اطلاق
النار
المبعوث الامميه كدان طرفي صراع ادرك
خطوره الوضع ووافقا على محادثات فنيه
للوصول الى غده
اداره
الاعمال الفنيه هلا مع الامريكان
والسعوديين فبطئت بالارجح
سيتم الارجح طبعا يعني الجانبين لازم ان
يوافقوا على
هذا المكان
باختص قال ان طرفي النزاع في السودان باتا
يدركان ان الانتصار العسكري لن يكون الا
بثمن باهض على سودان لاحظنا في الاسبوع
الاخير تكريما تغيير
باللهجه ويمكن تغيير تغيير خلينا بنقول
بالوعي او بادراك الطرفين لخطور الوضع
لانه وين بتعرف يعني بالاسبوع الاول
الاسبوع الثاني
فالجهتين كانوا
يعني كانوا يعبروا عن تاكيد انهم سيمتصرون
على الجانب التعنيف
كانوا يطلبون باستسلام الجانب الثاني الى
اخره انا بتائده انه في ادراك اكثر حاليا
انه الالتصار العسكري غير ممكن
الا لسعر
عالي جدا
وفي مقابل اعمال التهدئه كان رئيس الكيني
واليوم روتو ان طرفي صراع في السودان رفض
الاستجابه لدعوته جاد والاتحاد الافريقي
والمجتمع الدولي لوصف اطلاق النار واضاف
خلال اجتماع مع مسؤولين افارقه وامميين ان
الازمه الانسانيه في السودان وصلت الى
مستويات كارثيه وسط نقص في المياه والغذاء
والادويه مشيرا الى ان عدد النازحين مستمر
في الارتفاع مع فرار المزيد الى دول
الجغرا
للحديث عن التطورات في السودان معنا من
واشنطن السفير تيبور ناج مساعد وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي للشؤون الافريقيه سابقا
سيد ناجي اهلا وسهلا بك الى هذه التغطيه
هل توقعت وصول الازمه في السودان الى ما
وصلت اليه من اشتباكات ما بين الدعم
السريع والقوات المسلحه السودانيه
للاسف توقعت ذلك فبعد ان تفجر القتال
اعتقدت ان الجانبين
متساويان وهما يستغلان مزاياهما قلت يريد
تحقيق النصر وكل طرف كان له لم يكن لديه
ما يدفعه لوقف اطلاق النار وبالتالي
فللمؤسف الجواب على سؤالك هو نعم ولكن اين
الخطا الذي حدث سودان كان مسار لمصالح
وتنافس دولي كان هناك مبعوط اممي على اكثر
من مره وايضا هناك تواجد سياسي للولايات
المتحده الامريكيه اين الخطا الذي قاد الى
التطورات الاخيره
ان الخطا كان هو ان الجميع كانوا متفائلين
جدا
وما قاموا به هو انهما اعطى
الفريقين
موقفا لان
المتنازعين كان يريدان حكومه مدنيه
ولكن في نهايه المطاف كان هناك فقدان
للتواصل بين المجتمع الدولي
والجنرال
الموقف الامريكي والغياب سياسه الامريكيه
عن السودان لصالح مثلا سياسات دوليه للصين
وروسيا هي ايضا
جانب من الاخطاء التي حصلت وتسببت فيما
يدور حاليا
لا اتحدث نيابه عن ادوات المتحده
الامريكيه منذ مغادره لمنصبي ولكن اقول
انه المتحده دائما ساعدت الى تحقيق السلام
وانهائي القتال وترى برامج المساعدات التي
قدمتها الولايه المتحده في مجالات مثل
الصحه فالولايات المتحده بدات قصارى جهدها
لتحقيق السله بالنسبه
للروس فهي تتسبب المشكلات تنظر الى مجموعه
ومقامت به في الكثير من البلدان الافريقيه
تحديدا والصينيون يريدون التحقيق الارباح
ولكن عندما تتحول امور الى الى الصعوبه
الكبيره في الصينيون يتراجعون وهم لا
يتمخضون في الجهود التي ترمي الى حل
المشكله هناك مبادره امريكيه سعوديه
مطروحه على الطاوله الان لا توجد تفاصيل
اضافيه بشانها ولكن برايك ما العناصر
الاساسيه لنجاح اي مبادره في السودان
اعتقد ان اساس اي
مبادره يجب ان
يرتكز على الصدق الطرفين في احترامي وقف
اطلاق النار هذا اولا ثانيا عدم استخدام
وقف اطلاق النار
لتحقيق المكاسب لاحقا والا سيكون هناك هدى
جزئيه لكن الجانبين يواصلان المناوره
لتحقيق مزايا خاصه كان هناك تحضيرات من ان
تتحول هذه المواجهه الى تحولات طائفيه ليس
فقط في السودان بل على مستوى
الاقليم هل تتخوف من ذلك ايضا
بالتاكيد هذا هو ما اخشاه اكثر من اي شيء
اخر فتعلم ان السودان له سبعه دول مجاوره
وكل بلد من هذه البلدان لديها مشكلته
داخليه انظر الى تشاد وجمهوريه افريقيا
الوسطى وصولا الى ليبيا واثيوبيا تتجاوز
للتو مشكله عويسه واجهتها اذا نعم لا
اتوقع ان يكون هناك حرب اهليه على النموذج
السوري لنا في سوريا الحكومه حاربت شعبها
مع الراهن للاسف في هذه الحاله السودانيه
هو ان قوات الدعم السريع يمكن ان تتمركز
في الجنوب
والجيش يركز على الوساطه ويتواصل الامر
ليس كحرب اهليه ولكن كقتال جهوي في
السودان واستق الله جنوب السودان وكان
هناك مخاوف من ان تستقل دا رفور واقليم
سودانيه اخرى هل السودان معرض للتقسيط
الى مساله وجهها جدا
لمدى التاريخ واجه السودان مشكلات بين
المركز على امتداد النيل والمناطق الاخرى
نعلم انها تنشط في السودان واذا ما بدات
هذه المنشيات بينحياز الى احد الطرفين
المتنازل لا اعتقد ان هذا سيؤدي الى تجزئه
السودان ولكن الى صراعات اقليميه هل
الموقف الدولي الذي يتعامل مع طرفيا نزاع
على مسافه واحده منطقي عندما نتحدث مثلا
عن قوات بدات بمليشيات في دارفور وقوات
نظاميه تتبع للدوله السودانيه
المشكله بالنسبه لها السودان
الواقع ان السودان كان لديه تقريبا جيشا
نظاميا تعلم ان الجيش
السوداني له الاسلحه الثقيله والطائرات
ولكن القوات الدعم السريع مسلحه جيدا ايضا
الامر لا يتعلق
بجيش جدا ليسا وانما هي حرب بين جيشين
وهذا من اوجه تعقيدات الكبرى فاما ان يفوز
جانب على الطرف الاخر او ان يتوقف احد
جانبين والا لن يكون هناك اي حافز يا سلام
ولا اعتقد ان هناك اكتراث بما يواجهه
المدنيون
اعرف
بانكليزي سياسه في هذه المرحله ولكن اذا
اطيحت لك الفرصه
بالعوده او الى العوده الى المنصب هل هناك
نصائح معينه يمكن توجيهها لاي دبلوماسي
الدولي او حتى امريكي للخروج من هذه
الازمه او لاعطاء نصائح للسودانيه للخروج
من الازمه
انه عندما كنت مساعد لوزير الخارجيه لما
احبذ تلقي نصائح من اطراف خارجيه ولكن انت
محق عندما تنظر الامور من الخارج قد يكون
لديك رؤيه مختلفه ما يقلقني حقا هو ان في
ان كل بلد يتواصل الان مع الجنرلين وهناك
ربما ازدحام فيما يخص مقترحات وقف اطلاق
النار والسلامات قد من الاهميه بمكان
المجتمع الدولي ان ينسق الاتصالات فيما
بينها
ويتم التحدث بصوت واحد بدل من ان يتلقى
الجنرالان 20 اتصالا هاتفيا يوميا
مساعد وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه للشؤون
الافريقيه سابقا شكرا جزيلا لك
وعلى الارض اتهم الدعم سريع الجيش
السوداني بتحويل مستشفى السلاح الطبي
باولدرمان الى منصه للقصف المدفعي واشار
في بان الله لان القصف العشوائي من مستشفى
سلاح الطبي ادى الى مقتل واصابتك وادر
طبيه بحسب تاكيدات الدعم السريع واضاف
ايضا ان طيران الجيش لا يزال يحلق في سماء
الخرطوم ويقصف احيان سكنيه
وكان الجيش السوداني قد اكد في بيان الله
لقوات الدعم السريع حشدت اكثر من 65 الف
عنصر وهل في مركبه للهجوم على الخرطوم قبل
الخامس عشر من ابريل لكن الجيش استطاع
التصدي لمحاولات انتشارهم مشيرا الى ان
الجيش تمكن في غضون اسبوعين من القتال ان
يخفض قدرات الدعم السريع القتاليه الى
النصف مضيفا انه تم احباط عده تحركات
لتعزيزات عسكريه للقوات الدعم السريع
قادمه من اتجاه الغرب الى الخرطوم
وفي المقابل نشرت قوات الدعم السريع لقطات
فيديو تظهر انتشار عناصرها في مبنى القصر
الجمهوري وسط العاصمه الخرطوم وقالت قوات
الدعم السريع انها تسيطر تماما على القصر
الجمهوري ومحيطه بالاضافه الى مبنى
الاذاعه والتلفزيون كما اكدت كما اكدت احد
قاده الدعم السريع ان سيطرتهم على القصر
الجمهوري تاتي ضمن مساحه دعم السريع
للحفاظ على ثروات الشعب السوداني
قوات الدعم السريع من داخل القصر الجمهوري
نود ان نوصل رساله
لشعبنا الكريم ولشرفاء القوات المسلحه
اولا
نناشد كل الشرفاء في قوات الشعب المسلح
بان هذا العمل الذي زدت فيه القوات
المسلحه هو عمل يخدم افراد واشخاص محددين
في القوات المسلحه والغرض الاساسي منه
النازل دارين السولو على سلطه الشعب
السوداني وعن طريق كوميتو نحن الان في
قوات الدعم السريع بالناشد كل القوات
المسلحه وشرفاء القوات المسلحه بانه نحن
ما عاد بالنسبه لهم وانما نحن نريد ان
نحافظ على سلطه الشعب ونقول للشعب
السوداني تواجد قوات الدعم السريع في داخل
القصف وفي كل ولايه الخرطوم القرض الاساسي
منه الحفاظ على سلطه الشعب
لو تابع تفاصيل منهم درمان مع صحفي في
مكتب العربي في السودان شهدي نادر اهلا بك
في شاهدي
هناك حديث الان عن تجدد الاشتباكات بشكل
كبير في مناطق متفرقه من ولايه الخرطوم
بما فيها العاصمه وام درمان بالتاكيد ما
التطورات لديكم
مرحبا نعم اليوم تجدد الاشتباكات
الطيران الجو السوداني حلقت بشكل مكثف في
تمام الخرطوم في سماء مدنها الثلاثه طلعات
جويه مكثفه واصوات مضادات ارضيه عده مناطق
تصاعدت منها الادخين اليوم بعد بدايه
تحليق الطيران الحربي في سماء الخرطوم
ضاحيه مدينه الخرطوم بحري هي كانت اكثر من
اكثر المناطق التي تصعدت منها الادخنه
ضاحيه شامبات حيث المقرر الوحده الطبيه
اللي هي قوات الدعم السريعه التي كانت
سابقا هي وسلاح المظلات وايضا من ضاحيه
كافوري كذلك اشتباكات اليوم في منطقه شرق
النيل وجنوب الخرطوم وفي محيط مطار
الخرطوم اليوم الهدنه التي تم تجديدها
المنتصف الى الامس شهدت خروقات بشكل مكثف
واتهام من قبل قوات الدعم السري للجيش
بانه قد قصفه وحدته الطبيه طيب اذا هو
الحديث عن قصف وحده طبيه تابعه مباشره
لقوات الدعم السريع وليس لوزاره الصحه
السودانيه
كما تعلم هناك
تعرضت عدد من المستشفيات بالقصف عدد من
المستشفيات
في مناطق العمليات الى العسكريه تتركز
فيها في منطقه وسط العاصمه وما بين القصر
الجمهوري والقياده العامه عدد من
المستشفيات اضطرت الى ان تخرج الى ان تخرج
من الخدمه هذا الامر ادى الى اخلائها بشكل
شيبي كامل بشكل كامل الى ذلك
انقطاع الامداد الكهربائي انقطاع المياه
كل ذلك تسبب في ان تخرج هذه المستشفيات عن
الخدمه عوده المستشفيات
الطرفيه في اطراف مدن الخرطوم الثلاثاء
العمل ولكن هي ايضا تواجه صعوبات من عدم
توفر الكادر الطبي والصعوبات التي تواجهها
الكادر الطبيه في الوصول للمستشفيات هناك
نقص في المعينات هناك جهود رسميه وشعبيه
لتكمله هذا النص ولكن الاشعه الاستيعابيه
لهذه المستشفيات وتصميمها يفوق اعدادا
المرضى والمصابين الذين يحتاجون لتلقي
العلاج مره اخرى الى الاحاديث والبيانات
التي اعلنها الطرفان فيما يتعلق بالسيطره
على مناطق بعينها في السودان قوات الدعم
السريعه تنشر مقاطع مصوره تقول بانها من
القصر الجمهوري الاذاعه القصر الجمهوري
القياده العامه هل هناك من حديث عن سيطره
ولكن قبل ذلك نتابع مؤتمر للخارجيه
الامريكيه بشان تطورات الوضع في السودان
حلفائنا على حد
فيما يتعلق بعمليه من السودان متى تم
تيسير
القافله ثالثه هل كان هناك ثلاث قوائف في
قافلتان فقط
اذا القافله الاولى كانت يوم السبت هل تم
تيسير القافلتين الثاني والثالثه يوم
الاحد ساعطيك التاريخ المحدد ولكن
القافله الثالثه وصلت في وقت مبكر اليوم
الى بورس سودان ادرك انه كان انكم لا
تريدون اعطاء ارقام ولكن لا ارى يمكن ان
يكون ذلك مشكله ما هو عدد المواطنين
الامريكيين او الذين يحوزون الاقامه
الامريكيه قد حصلوا على المساعده من
السلطات القنصليه لا استطيع ان اعطيك
اجابه الدقيقه لذلك فمنذ بدا اعمالا عن
اتفهم سؤالك اذا الجواب هو كلا ولكن يجب
ان نتذكر ان جده ليست المكان الوحيد ان
اطرح عليك السؤال انا اتفهم هذا السؤال
انا لا اسالك عن جده
لديكم ارقام بعدد المواطنين الذين تم
اجلائهم هذه عمليه لا تزال متواصله اذن من
الواضح انكم لا تريدون الاجابه على هذا
السؤال تفضل
المواطن الذين تم اجلؤهم اذن ما هو عدد
المواطنين الامريكيين من بين هؤلاء
الاشخاص السبعمائه الذين تم اجلاؤهم ليس
لدي عدد محدد بشانهم اشرتم الى خمسه الاف
ثم تقولون الان الرقم هو الف هل لكم ان
تحددوا لنا ما هي الارقام الدقيقه بشان
المواطنين الامريكي رغم من تبقى منهم في
السودان
ينبغي ان نتذكر هميره بانه ليس كل
المواطنين الامريكيين الذين وصلوا الى
مكان امنه انهم
لم يعودوا مدرجين ضمن قوائم الاشخاص الذين
يريدون الاجلاء وبالتالي نستطيع نعطيك
ارقام محدده بهذا الشهر
بناء عما تفضلت به حتى الان
عدد 700 هو
ضمن عمليات الاجلاء التي تمت منذ يوم
السبت اذا 700
متضامن ضمن الالف شخص ليس لدي اي ارقام
محدده بشان المواطنين الامريكيين وغيرهم
الذين يحملون الجنسيات الاخرى الذين تم
اجلائهم من السودان اشرت الى القافله
الثانيه
منذ بدا العمل عنف وتشديداتها استطعنا ان
نجلي حوالي 1000 مواطن امريكي من خلال
اليات اخرى مثل الرحلات التي ينظمها
شركائنا وكذلك عبر قوافل تنظمها المنظمات
دوليه اذا نحن نعطيكم هذه الارقام وفقا
اما يصلنا ولكن بينما يتواصل المواطنين
امريكيون
بالمصالح القنصليه
نستطيع ان نعطي ارقاما مدققه اشرت الى 700
700 شخص وانا افترض ان يوجد بينهم مواطن
امريكيين هذا صحيح
الرقم الذي اعطيته لكم سوف يرتفع بناء على
ذلك
تفضلي
المواطن العدد الف او المواطن الامريكي
الذين بلغ عددهم الف وتم اجلائهم من
السودان ومن خلال عمليات الاجلاء بمساعده
الشركاء هل
يمكن ان تؤكدوا في الطريقه التي تم
اجلاؤهم بها هل هي بر او عبر وسائل اخرى
الوضع متغير بشكل كبير
ونحن نواصل تقديم المعلومات قدر على
المستطاع ولدي سؤال اخر
يعني بعض السفن في بورت السودان
التقرير بشانها
والسعتها هي دون عشرين بالمئه هل لكم علم
بالمواقع الامريكيين الذين ربما تم
اجلائهم على متن هذه السفن ليست لديها
معلومات محدده يمكن ان اعطيها لك ما اود
ان الاحظه ان
القوافل التي قمنا بتنظيمها لم تكون
مكتمله الاعداد لان الوضع الامني متغير
جدا واستطعنا ان ننقل الاشخاص الذين تمكنا
من اجلائهم ولكنني لست على علم بهذه
الحاله الخاصه التي اشرت اليها
نكتفي بهذا الجانب من المؤتمر الصحفي
لبدنت بديل نائب المتحدث باسم وزاره
الخارجيه الامريكيه وكان يتحدث عن عمليات
الاجلال للرعايه الامريكيين من السودان
توقع مسؤول اللاجئين في الامم المتحده
فيليبوغراندي فراره ما يفوق 800 الف شخص
من السودان اثرا النزاع في البلاد كما
اضاف جراندي ان 73 الف شخص فرو متجهين الى
دول الجوار وفي سياق ذاته عبر منسق الامم
المتحده لشؤون الانسانيه عن مخاوفه من
امتداد ازمه السودان الى دول الجوار واعلن
المنسق ان الوضع الانساني في البلاد يتجه
الى نحو كارثي وان شحنه من الادويه عالقه
على الحدود ولم تدخل السودان بعد
[موسيقى]
اتجه اليها الوضع الانساني في السودان
منسق الامم المتحده للشؤون الانسانيه في
السودان وصف الوضع بالكارثه متخوفا من
امتداد الازمه لدول الجوار
[موسيقى]
تصريحات داعمه لما سبق ادلى بها مسؤول
اللاجئين في الامم المتحده متوقعا فرار
اكثر من 800 الف شخص من السودان
بالاضافه الى 73 الف شخص لاذو بالفرار الى
دول الجوار
هروب جماعي من المعارك والوضع الصحي
المزري مع استمرار خروج المشافي عن الخدمه
ومقص التجهيزات
بينما تواجه شحنه ادويه من الصحه العالميه
عوائق للدخول الى البلاد
هذا وحضرت لجنه الدوليه الاحمر في السودان
من ان الاوضاع الانسانيه سيئه جدا وان ذلك
يدفع بصليب الاحمر الى التركيز على القطاع
الصحي لايصال المساعدات الطبيه
الاوضاع الانسانيه سيئه جدا وهناك كوارث
الاولويه القصوى بالنسبه للصليب الاحمر هي
القطاع الصحي حيث تعاني المستشفيات من عدم
توفر المياه والكهرباء وانها غير قادره
على العمل لذلك المستشفيات بحاجه الى
مساعدات طبيه كبيره جدا وعلينا البدء
بتقديم الدعم المطلوب وتوفير المستلزمات
الطبيه واللقاحات اللازمه
عمليه اجلال رعايه دول الاجنبيه من شرق
السودان صوبا ميناء جده وعبر مطار
بورسودان دخلت يومها العاشر اكثر من 16
الف طالب اجلاء غادروا البلاد من خلال شرق
السودان خلال الايام الماضيه غير ان الافا
من السوريين واليمنيين ومقيمين سودانيين
في عدد من الدول العربيه يواجهون صعوبات
في سبيل مغادرتهم السودان العربيه ترصد
الواقعه من شرق السودان
عشره ايام مضت على اول عمليه اجلاء لرعايه
دول الاجنبيه من شرق السودان نحو مختلف
الدول العالم عبر ميناء بورسودان وعبر
مرها الدولي اكثر من عشرين رحله بحريه تمت
حتى الان ونحو 45 رحله جويه من مطار
بورسودان الدولي تستمر عمليات الاجلاء دون
توقف غير ان اوضاع الرعايه السوريين
المطالبين بجلائهم تشكل استثناء هنا عم
نطلب
من الوحده نروح نحن اي بلد
فيزا اربيل العراق مصر اي اي مكان ما حدا
سال علينا العيال في الشوارع النساء
الشباب مضى معه مصاري
الحمد لله الشعب السوداني ما مقصر ابدا لا
من اكل لا من ملبس لا من ماء
هذا الوضع اضبط الاخرى تشهدها المنافذ نحو
الخارج حيث يواجه السودانيون المقيمون في
عدد من الدول ظروفا صعبه يقول كثير منهم
ان اوضاعهم لا تحتمل تاخر اجراءات
مغادرتهم للسودان نحن اننا زيارات يعني في
ناس
طيب
وبالناس كل السلطات يا جماعه انه لو في
امكانيه توفر لنا بواخر نحن بحقنا بتذاكر
بنشتري كل السودانيين
مستطيعين انهم يدفعوا حق التذاكر بس ما
موجوده نحن كسودانيين مقيمين في السعوديه
ناشط السلطات السودانيه والسلطات السعوديه
انه يسرعوا في اجراءات اجلانا من مدينه
بورسودان الى المملكه العربيه السعوديه
لانه عندنا طلبه عندهم جامعات وعندهم اسر
الشفقانين عنوان شديد ولازم يصلون باسرع
وقت
للمواجهات المسلحه ارتدادات مختلفه يامل
كثيرون هنا ان لا تتمدد لتشمل قطاعات اخرى
نزار البداوي لقناتي العربيه والحدث مدينه
بورسودان الشرقيه السودان
اعلنت نقابه اطباء السودان عن ارتفاع عدد
قتل الاشتباكات الدائره في البلاد الى 436
شخصا كما اكدت ان عدد المصابين ارتفع الى
ما يزيد عن
2275 شخصا في صفوف البدنيين نقابه الاطباء
السودانيين قالت ايضا ان هناك الكثير من
الاصابات والوفيات غير مشموله في هذا
الحصر بسبب صعوبه الوصول الى المستشفيات
مضيفه ان الاشتباكات القبليه في مدينه
الجنينه بولايه غرب دارفور اسفرت عن سقوط
94 قتيلا مشيرا الى ان جميع المستشفيات لا
تعمل في المدينه حتى الان
السودان نظام الرعايه الصحيه على وشك
الانهيار الصحه العالميه اكدت وقوع 26
هجوما على مرافق الرعايه الصحيه منذ
اندلاع الصراع بالسودان
وتقول ان المستشفيات تعرضت لقصف واغلق
ثلثاها في الخرطوم نقابه اطباء السودان
حذرت من الانهيار الكامل للنظام الرعايه
الصحيه
الصليب الاحمر العاملون في مجال الرعايه
الصحيه في السودان يفعلون المستحيل يعتنون
بالجرحى بدون ماء وكهرباء وامدادات طبيه
اساسيه
منظمات غير حكوميه تبذل جهودا لانقاذ
القطاع الصحي في السودان في ظل المعارك
المتواصله
منظمه اطباء بلا حدود قالت انها تبرعت
بمستلزمات طبيه لثلاثه مستشفيات في
الخرطوم
ومن الصليب الاحمر وصلت اول شحنه من
الامدادات الطبيه الى السودان
وطائره ثانيه ستنقل امدادات طبيه اضافيه
وموظفين في مجال الطوارئ
حضرت صحيفه البريطانيه من ان عمليه
الاختراع على المختبر البيولوجي في
السودان ينذر بنوشوب حرب بيولوجيه تهدد
المنطقه والعالم
الاستيلاء على مختبر بيولوجي في السودان
بقوه السلاح يثير مخاوف من حرب بيولوجيه
محتمله من خلال نشر امراض خطيره وقاتله
تضاهي خطورتها الحروب النوويه وفق بيانات
كشفت عنها صحيفه ذا تيليجراف البريطانيه
تحذر من عصر جديد ومرعب متمثل بحرب
بيولوجيه بعد افتتاح اكثر من عشره مختبرات
عاليه المستوى للسلام البيولوجيه في جميع
انحاء العالم عقب ظهور فيروس كورونا
البيانات اشهرت الى ان الخطر الكبير يكمن
في السودان والمنطقه بعد الاستحواذ على
صرح طبي عريق في الخرطوم عمره 100 عام
شيدته بريطانيا لاغراض طبيه
الخطر القادم ياتي بسبب انقطاع التيار
الكهربائي عن المختبر الذي يقع في قلب
المواجهات الدائره في البلاد ما يصعب
الحفاظ على تلك العينات الحساسه والمسببه
لامراض كالحصبه والكوليرا واخرى خطيره
مميته
اكثر من ذلك مواجهات السودان تعقد اصلا
عمليه مراقبه اي تسرب محتمل من المختبر ما
يزيد مخاوف الصحه العالميه التي حذرت من
خطر بيولوجي كبير وهي التي فشلت باداره
ملف وباء كورونا الذي عطل العالم لاكثر من
عامين تقول صحيفه
خلال العشرين سنه الماضيه تصاعد التهديد
البيولوجي واصبح يشكل تهديدا مباشرا
للبشريه بعد تسرب فيروسات او بكتيريا
خطيره عن طريق الخطا او العمد ورغم ذلك
فان الاليه الدوليه الرسميه شبه غائبه وفق
ذا تيليجراف
محاسن حضاره العربيه
20 الف لاجئ سوداني يعانون مراره الجو في
تشاد اغلبيتهم من النساء والاطفال ومنهم
من يعانون من امراض تنفسيه خطيره غير ان
اليونيسيف حذرت من البقاء في قريه كفرونه
شاديه خوفا من موسم الامطار المقبل
لاجئه سودانيه دون مواعيد
بعضهن تمكنا من الدفع فقل عليهن عبء
الطريق نساء واطفال هربوا من حرب اشتعلت
فجاه خيار اللجوء لا مفر منه ضمن حرب
بحصيله كبيره للقتله
ثلاثه نفر اربعه كده عشان كده
استقروا هنا على الحدود التشاديه
السودانيه كبرات السن لم تعد لهن القدره
على المضي بينما الاطفال اغلبهم يعانون من
امراض تنفسيه وسوء تغذيه
الف لاجئ سوداني استقروا في قريه كوفرون
تشاديه قريه تفتقر لاساسيات الحياه وضروره
تغيير المكان باتت حتميه
اذا فشلنا في التحرك الان سيفوت الاوامر
سياتي موسم الامطار قريبا واذا لم نقدم
مساعده للناس سيتم اغلاق الطريق وسيظل
اللاجئون عالقين هنا
يبدو ان البقاء هنا طويل مخيم اللجوء باتت
تتشكل ملامحهم عشرات الاسقف واعمده علها
تشد بيت لاجئ الى حين عوده غيداء السالم
العربيه
في مشهد مؤثر ضمن عمليات الاجلاء نقل
افراد من البحريه السعوديه شابا من ذوي
الاعاقه من بناء بورسودان الى سطح سفينه
جلاله الملك الدرعيه المتجهه الى جده
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات